younsi squeeze un trauma les ans
aujourd'hui nous sommes sûr cela
poillion nadjaf et 600 milliards de jeux
croyez moi je les souhaite celui-ci
mieux que ceux d'avant et chaque fois je
dis ça tu es moiroud va s'appeler mastoc
où commence directement un jeu de mots
mais comme ça donc dans un foyer ovo
contrôler notre personnage avec zqsd et
on bouge la masse avec la souris et le
but c'est de tuer les gens avec cette
masse par exemple à il nous a vus fils
de [ __ ] unis qui montrent selon lui par
exemple il a une énorme aspect cool tu
regarde et on va le clôturer
bon les gars je suis mastoc mammas va
devenir toc c'est hyper nul ce que je
dis oh oui et là hop hamas devenu un
gros elle devient énorme
elle est bien énorme et sèche elle a
regardé les vidéos je dirais pas du
capital et je vais la voir mais je dois
aussi ok corral et faure qui se balance
sur une fantastique ou pas attendu fois
que youtube ah oui rien à tanger s'est
dit ce qu'ils ont or il a tellement bien
qu'il apaloo balle au bas des piles api
lyon l'a vu à l'est et donc plus elle
est grosse plus elle va loin aussi un
c'est très bizarre
brossard 1989 c'est parce qu'un 2000
noms et aux mais ils sont forts les gens
ça suffit j'en ai marre voilà moi je
vais dans une game il ya que des nuls
c'est le retour de xxx c'est au tour de
vis n'diaye a battu vignal je peux le
mettre en miniature ça prend plus honda
détient la double qu abbas et sa tumeur
un cérusé un bon en fait je pense que le
but sinon tu es à l'aise devant toi et
ça te protège en fait en vrai
ben ça je suis pas foutu l'illustré
correctement au bordel de merde est
taillé pour nous sur le tueur au design
your say you ou étaient morts côté morts
oui tu as chaud là bas je suis une bonne
lancée mon gars faut surtout pas qu'on
s'arrête là when a man mégane est trop
chaud [ __ ] il y en a qui sont énormes
ont bien fait quoi toi tu fais quoi tu
as mais non le mec qu'il arrive il se
régale quoi je le déteste quoi
improbable ça c'est dû à l'autre à 60 au
scoop dans call of duty et andy allait
cela raconte attention c'est bon c'est
bon on a chaud un éléphant qui se
balançait sur une toi de toi le toit le
toile toile d'araignée c'était un jeu
tellement tellement amusant que si on
tue quoi aulas l'a tassé la bataille de
titans boga attention on va la voir dans
la mort va aller c'est fini qu'il faut
que tu lui faut que tu oublies fitch dit
mais non tu vois là là j'ai senti
l'éléphant n'était pas avec nous là sur
ce point [ __ ] ça c'est moi qui ai pas
de classement on aimerait bien voir un
glissement 1 pour voir qui a la plus
grosse un an faut que tu faut que tu as
évoqué la grosse masse non j'ai raté ma
chance comme ça et tu te gay il a plus
de porte et je y avait eu le droit de
l'udc une fois trahi par le poids de
francs rien faire en [ __ ] eu qu une
chose aisée chez devoir être ailleurs oh
oui donne moi donne moi ta masse au
lalalalalala mais qui peut le stopper
vient de loin à vue sont à 9 h aux biens
je vais interdire cette façon ça fait
200 mieux qu'on l'a dit et à chaque fois
c'est le même résultat
auger j'ai cru j'écris au c'est beau à
temps on pourrait carrément monté un
groupe d'acrosport avec ces gens et
avoir un sûrement au bac et ben voila et
sauf claire 1 à 0 et on meurt un super
mois égale danger c'est vrai pour de
vrai bon je suis pas sûr je pense
qu'hier sur un chantier de là à ce stade
à base d'amiante a pris en chasse et aux
sommes énormes et si ça veut dire le
plus au nord en espagne tuez pas les
hispaniques se peut tout dire ça c'est
pourquoi se dire le pylône heures parce
que l histoire du petit éléphant mignon
et sa toile d'araignée s'est fêlé là on
va pilonner ah oui marteau piqueur oh
oui oui au pilote bel honneur qui tua
frère
mon gars je suis réputé dans le milieu
il ya un [ __ ] de moucherons des gages
qui peut tuer le puits l'honneur oh là
là on commence à avoir une sacrée vaste
soutien au [ __ ] ça c'est dit du pylône
heures ça allait au bonjour à tous puis
l'odeur est le pylône est à présent
l'homme papables comme dirait rihanna oh
mon dieu j'ai rencontré un autre puis
l'honneur aux mondieux sa [ __ ] [ __ ]
il met en place la dégage toi [ __ ]
c'est ce qu'on appelle un moteur qu'il
s'appelle own sa pizza est plus petit
peut nous arrêter qui peut réellement
stopper puis l'honneur dans le game
écouter les amis on est sur notre troll
tout le monde a abdiqué devant nous ils
sont tous devraient quitter la gagne
après personnes ont effectué avec minrex
oh là là j'adore ce qu'on a ce type ça
me plaît énormément à ce qui se passe
c'est même plus drôle âge et toute la
masse du jour là ou là ou là ou là c'est
chaud là c'est chaud c'est chaud c'est
chaud pour se concentrer non à joyce est
le grand gagnant
allait elle pilote at all is back oui
vous pouvez pas empêcher un roi de
retourner sur son trône aux plaquettes
eu affaire regarde moi ça me regarde
elle pilote vous avez vu ça il n'a pas
été pistonné on peut dire que son père
faisait pas des travaux était boulanger
il s'est fait tout seul faire oh [ __ ]
serait ce l marteau pas tort
l'ennemi juré des le pilote à tort au
yen est morte on t'attend hélas hélas
matin entre les deux rivaux mondiaux
oui fait l'hôte à tort il est la pierre
pesait de la france aux jo à rio un jour
rien ne peut empêcher un roi de
récupérer le trône juillet faut voir
grâce elle mêle marteau 14 mai avant
qu'il devienne 27 ans l'acl
ben voilà georges des mets pas ça tu
payes welch ancien parti des ressources
la moyenne n'hésitez pas à aller mais ça
vous a plu j'ai adoré ce [ __ ] de jeu
pour ayew je trouve génial sur sarthon
cool de gérer ses mouvements mais j'ai
réussi les mouvements de la masse
l'inertie elle est assez bien fait donc
ça on le truc un peu complexe et un peu
ce qui les mine de rien mais ce n'est
pas un problème pour moi j'ai un chapeau
visible basse avoir gardé un trou dans
une prochaine vidéo part de vos biens
jato office